Film Courage: I’m not sure if you’re okay
talking about this but did you go through
a period of time where you were not able to
pay your bills being a cinematographer?
Andy Rydzewski, Cinematographer: I’m happy
to discuss that, yes.
I’ve been in Los Angeles for 15 years (something
like that) and I’ve been broke for probably
11 of them, 10…something like that?
Problematically broke for five, six years
and I feel very lucky.
This is one of the things that I am always
very thankful for is that I always knew that
I wanted to be involved in filmmaking or at
least from a very young age.
I didn’t know if it was realistic.
My mother wanted me to be a doctor.
My whole family are doctors except for me.
But I just loved it so much…filmmaking…the
idea of it and any little taste I got.
I slept in my car…my last semester of undergrad
I slept in my car.
I went to the gym in the morning to shower.
I never felt…it kind of felt romantic.
I never felt like I was sacrificing even though
I guess I was, it didn’t feel that way because
I was pursuing this kind of weird dream and
it always and money…I will say it’s tricky
if you’re raising a family and all of that
but for me it has always served me well to
ignore money in the jobs I pursue and all
of that.
I have friends who are doing well in let’s
say the commercial world or the corporate
world in terms of filmmaking and they will
tell me that they are envious of me because
I’ve shot some features and TV shows but
then something will come their way some low-budget
feature and they will say no because of the
pay is no good.
But then they get frustrated that they are
not getting a feature but they just want…and
narrative pays worse than commercials.
That is generally the rule and for me ignoring
the money and just chasing the project or
the director has served me very well.
Some of the best, some of the jobs you know
I think about the last show I shot which was
PEN15 a Hulu series and that director worked
together on multiple projects.
We shot a series before for Seeso which is
a defunct streaming service and we shot a
web series for I think it was three days or
four days of shooting.
I think I got paid $100.00 and I worked my
tail off and still to this day it’s one
of my favorite things that I shot.
I believe for him he got his manager from
that.
He had a screening, it went very well.
It kind of kicked things off for him and at
the time when he asked me to do it I did hesitate.
I was like “Well…okay.
It barely pays.”
Like it’s barely paying me anything and
then I did it and I loved it!
I loved the project.
I love everybody involved.
A lot of those people are doing well these
days and it’s a piece of my community in
Los Angeles came from that tiny webseries
so for me…and we will see now.
We are in a pandemic as we speak and I haven’t
worked in months and I was okay with it for
a time and now the anxiety is starting to
creep in but you know I’ve been freelance
for 15 years and I am used to all manner of
ups and downs and I keep my overhead low so
that I don’t have to chase money I guess…yes.
Film Courage: Were you actively looking for
jobs or because so much of the film industry
just completely shut down…?
Andy: So yes now at this point the only thing
that I have done to be proactive really is
I am not really active with social media and
I realize that for my job I probably should,
I should make that a higher priority and I
do have friends who are really good with Instagram
specifically and I realize that it has the
potential to be a good tool for finding work
and so I am now trying to treat it a little
more seriously and trying to create posts
that I would like to see.
Maybe a little educational or a behind the
scenes or how did you light this or why is
the color palette this?
That kind of thing so I am trying to now just
so I feel proactive because I don’t really
know what else I can be doing to find work.
I’ve built a decent network over the years.
I have a reputation that I am proud of but
when people aren’t calling I’m genuinely
not sure of what one does and I am learning.
I’m trying to figure it out.
I’m talking to different people and seeing
what they think and just kind of trusting
that something will come.
The last show I shot did well in terms of
its reviews and finding an audience so I am
hoping that that might put my name on some
lists but the truth is so much of this is
a crapshoot.
I really don’t know how to find work even
when a decade ago I woke up every day and
I would start on Craigslist and Mandy (dot)
com was a thing but I was trying to do that
the other day I was like curious if people
were posting jobs during all of this.
But I have never been sure how to find work.
It’s never made sense to me.
But I have been okay at building relationships
and not in an aggressive networking way I
don’t think.
It’s mostly I’m a big film nerd and I
end up bonding with people who are also film
nerds and the directors who I have bonded
with, it tends to be somebody who I met somewhere
and we just got to talking about some movie
that we saw and then it snowballs and you’re
like “Have you ever seen this movie?”
And just the excitement of it and I think
that is one of the arguments for being in
Los Angeles is you are around other people
who are chasing the same dream and a lot of
them you will find people who are nerdy in
the same way you’re nerdy and then you bond
and then going back to what I was saying earlier
about how you are on set that often starts
way before.
It could be a job interview but ideally it’s
a social setting.
You are meeting a friend of a friend of a
friend at somebody’s birthday and you are
like “Oh?
I really liked that person.
What do they do?
Oh…cinematographer.
Well you know we have this thing coming up.”
I think that how a lot of Los Angeles connections
get made and I think that was the downside
of going to such a small school is that I
came to LA with zero connections and I think
that people who got to USC for instance which
is way more expensive so it has that downside
but I think you are meeting people who are
going to be in the industry for the next decade
at least and I think that gives you a real
head start in a lot of ways and now I don’t
know in terms of film education or the debt
and all of that.
I don’t know the pros and cons but I think
yes meeting people which again in a pandemic
is tricky.
I have no idea how I am going to meet people
but again there are film groups that are meeting
on zoom and I should maybe try to be more
proactive about that and doing something like
this.
Who knows?
Who knows who will see the interview and be
like “Hey!
That guy.”
Film Courage: “I like him!
I want to meditate in my car with him.”
Andy: Exactly, right!
So you never know but I’ve never been good
at how to get work, how to summon work.
It’s definitely one of the, I’m fond of
saying this but I think it’s true, I am
bad at the business side of the business.
Film Courage: I see a lot of true artists
are that way.
Andy: Yes, I have a lot of musician friends
and some of the best ones are terrible at
every other part of life so yes, I don’t
know what one does with that but you just
kind of trust and I think the fact that I’ve
been freelance for so long and I’ve gone
through such lean times it prepares you for
future lean times.
So far I feel okay.
I think I told myself I’m allowed to get
anxious next March.
One year, at the one year anniversary if I
still have no work then I am allowed to start
getting a little anxious.
Film Courage: 2021?
Andy: 2021.
I’m a little ahead of schedule.
I got anxious for the first time a week or
two ago, I’ve got to…that is not part
of the deal so I’ve got to keep my…because
I know as soon as I end up on set and I am
on week four and I’m exhausted I’m going
to be like “Ahhh!
Remember when it was a pandemic and I could
just sleep whenever I wanted?”
So I will be wishing for this downtime.
Film Courage: Well if we go back to 1918,
was it the Spanish Flu?
So was that two years if we look at the chart?
I’m not really sure but if we think about
medical advances are far greater now than
then and there is the whole thing does anyone
want to take a vaccine?
We won’t go down that slippery slope but
when you were talking about 2009 and The [Los
Angeles] Station Fire and all of that was
tragic.
We probably thought we’d never see anything
like that in our lifetime again and now you
add a bad economy to a communicable disease
(sorry I can’t even say the word) so there
are new variables that we’ve never really
been in this situation before.
Andy: I will say I think that is always on
the table.
I think you know that life is change and as
soon as you think you have stability and a
predictability to your life I think something
is going to shake it up and that could be
the fire speaking but that is how certainly
I try not to take anything for granted or
assume.
I think also the film industry in and of itself
the number of projects that I was getting
ready to shoot that just fell through, I mean
it’s innumerable.
I was supposed to be shooting a feature this
summer that I was really excited about.
I had three features lined up this year and
poof you know.
But just in normal times that still happens
so I think being prepared for instability
in this industry is really important and weighing
if that is worth it.
I’m lucky, I don’t have a wife and kids
and so my anxiety, any anxiety that arises
is just for me.
I would imagine that for somebody with a family
you have to provide for, that’s…I don’t
see how that couldn’t raise your stress.
You know our industry is pretty cruel.
It chews you up.
It spits you out.
There is always somebody behind you in line
so I don’t know.
I think that is why you’ve really got to
love it because otherwise I do not recommend
getting into this industry and I’m lucky
because I do love it.
I love it very purely so now we’ll see how
long that lasts.
I’m sure one morning I will wake up and
be like “Hmmm, I’m going to go see if
there is work at the gas station.”
Who knows?
Film Courage: Or you said you love ventriloquism
and things like that.
You never know, you might make a line of these
puppets?
Andy: That’s true.
Film Courage: There are new things that can
happen and sometimes we don’t even know
what are interests are.
Andy: That’s true, you never know and again
I try to be open to all those things.
Life is change and it’s all an adventure
and tick-tock.
Who knows how much time you’ve got left?
I think being open to any other experiences,
any other paths that reveal themselves in
life like I don’t know, take it.
Why not?
What the heck.
I’m always open to anything that might come
down the pike.
If I respond to it, that’s all I need and
then I will follow that.
Film Courage: When you look back at those
times when you were trying to find work and
they were lean times, did you lose faith in
yourself?
Did you ever say “You know what, I should
have done pre-med?”
Andy: Hmm…I think in my leaner times there
were certainly doubts that came up like is
this plausible.
I mean the truth is I still wonder can I do
this for another 10, 20, 30, 40 years and
I genuinely don’t know.
So I think there have been doubts in terms
of is this a lifestyle that I want to continue
pursuing, that is probably the bigger one.
I had a year 2017 which was my first really
busy year and I shot…I can’t remember…it
was like 30, 40 episodes of half hour various
shows, half hour TV.
It was just I went from one show to the next
to the next.
I spent six or seven months in other states
shooting and it was good obviously to be shooting.
I was so exhausted by the end of the year
that I felt really burnt out and I got freaked
out.
I was like “Oh no.
Can I not do this anymore?”
And it took me two months to recover just
sleeping basically for two months, I’ve
seen friends for the first time in a year
and it was the first time where I got scared
of what can happen in this industry on the
flip side.
I was used to being broke and not having work
and that brought its own anxiety and then
doing 13-hours days for a full year just ground
me down mentally and physically and so now
when I have the luxury of choosing jobs I
now pay attention who am I working with?
Is this really something that I feel a pull
toward?
And trying to weigh pros and cons of everything
because I really don’t know.
I really am scared of this industry.
I’ve watched it take more talented people
and spit them out and turn them bitter and
that’s something I am really worried about.
I don’t want that to be the case with me.
I want to make sure that I still love what
I am doing for as long as possible.
Part of that is meditation, going for evening
walks is like a huge thing.
It calms me down and all that.
When I am working on set on a show, I have
a lot of strict rules.
I have dietary rules and sleep rules that
I follow really closely because of that one
year.
It was just so intense that it freaked me
out.
So taking that experience and combining it
with years of being broke and having doubts
but always still just kind of okay, just keep
working on your craft and just hope I guess,
hope that something works out.
I don’t know, it’s all scary when I really
think about this industry it’s a tough one
to feel good about unfortunately.
I’m hoping I mean who knows this pandemic
maybe I’m hoping it will turn into…I’ve
heard some shows are switching to French hours
which means instead of a 12 and a half hour
day with a half hour lunch in the middle is
you work for 10 hours straight, you don’t
stop for lunch, it’s a walking lunch and
I would love that!
To go home 2 hours earlier is definitely worth
not sitting down for a half hour for lunch
but it helps your immune system.
We’re learning more about what lack of sleep
does to your body and it’s not good.
So I do hope that be it a certain director
or a certain studio or whatever it is that
quality of life could maybe move up the list
in terms of priorities.
That would be lovely.
I don’t have a lot of faith in that happening
but I do hope that there is a way to be doing
this well into my 70’s and still feel like
I am taking care of my life.
I don’t know if that is possible you know
but one can dream.
Question For The Viewers:
Which parts of this video are most valuable
to you?